hey guys so I was super lucky and I got
to play Dark Souls 3 today I got about
four or five hours with this demo built
that's going around Gamescom and I
played it with the sole intention of
getting a feel for exactly what is
different what is new and what you need
to know about the game so let me tell
you all about it the demo took place on
the wall of lot Aleph which apparently
has recently been under attack it was
filled with hollows and Dragons and the
corpses of Knights and the occasional
undead Knight
these are pretty standard enemies for an
early Souls game level and I expect this
to be an early level in the game level
design was compact and really vertical
in the sense that there were a lot of
ledge drops and walking on rooftops
ladders elevators and a ton of
unlockable shortcuts as well but this is
all standard stuff for a Souls game so
let's talk combat the newest addition to
combat is the weapon art mechanic
basically a weapon art is activated with
l2 and it's a mode that once entered
gives you access to a new set of moves
based on your weapon so for example
imagine that you have a shield in your
left hand and a straight sword in your
right when you hold down l2 your shield
will go on your back and your character
will hold the short sword out in front
of him indicating that you are now in a
weapon art stance while you are in this
webinar stance your r1 and r2 bumpers no
longer do their standard attacks instead
a stance r1 does this uppercut that is
intended to break an opponent's guard
stance Tartu makes your character dash
forward towards your target and then
stab at the end of the run so these are
weapon arts for the short sword but
every weapon is different with the great
sword pressing l2 doesn't put you into a
stance rather it slams the hilt of your
sword down vertically in front of you
and from here you can press r2 to do a
massive uppercut that will send your
opponent flying so the great sword
weapon art is more of a combo during
this uppercut attack you cannot be
staggered so it was wonderful against
heavily armored enemies but there is no
weapon art are
one with the great sword unlike the
short sword that had weapon art are ones
and artists to give you more examples
with the legion scimitar z' they didn't
appear to be any weapon art combo rather
you would press l2 and your character
would spin with both of the blades
it had a great cleave effect that was
wonderful for multiple enemies with the
battle ax weapon again there wasn't a
weapon art combo for this weapon instead
when you press tell to your character
did a battle cry that knocked the enemy
back and after this your weapon glowed
red and I believe it made you deal
additional damage a kind of like an
enraged effect that lasted for a little
while but if you're confused and I
understand if you are the take away for
what a weapon art is is that it's a way
for your weapon to have unique
properties or moves granted to it by the
pressing or holding down of l2 and it's
as simple as that every time you use one
of these weapon art techniques with l2
you use up what I'm going to call weapon
art points for lack of a better name in
the top left our character started with
20 of these points they were displayed
just below the Covenant marker which was
the sunlight Covenant by the way praise
the Sun so these points were used up
whenever you used a weapon art technique
some techniques used more points than
others the great sword used for one for
the initial slam and three for the
uppercut the short sword attacks used
one point each the battle ax used two
points and the scimitar spin used one
when you ran out of points these weapon
art techniques did less damage for
example my short sword attack did a
hundred and thirty-eight damage when I
had a weapon heart point and 98 damage
when I had no points remaining and as
far as I know the only way to replenish
these points was at the bonfire whether
you could use weapon arts at all was
actually designated by the type of
shield you used there were two types of
shield in the demo they were parrying
small shields and weapon art medium
shields they had a little symbol on them
which signified whether it was a parry
shield or whether it was a weapon art
shield if you had a parry shield l too
was parry instead of a weapon our
just like in all the previous games and
parrying is back in true Dark Souls 1
style in Dark Souls 1 you had to press
parry as soon as an attack connected
with your shield after this the enemy's
attacking arm was flung back and you
would stab them in the gut with a
riposte in Dark Souls 2 you had to press
parry slightly before the attack hit you
and then the enemy was knocked flat on
their back in Dark Souls 3 it's like it
was in Dark Souls 1 there's a small
parry window and you have to press parry
at the exact same time the attack
connects with you I'd say that it's
still slightly harder to parry than it
was in Dark Souls 1 though mainly
because enemies appeared to attack a
little bit faster and an increase in
speed is a good way to describe the demo
in general the soul series has always
been about being cautious and being
tactical you're encouraged to hide
behind your shield and manage your
stamina really well and try to find a
gap in your enemy's defenses blood-borne
broke the mold a little bit it
encouraged a proactive method to your
gameplay where you were the aggressive
one and an enemy had to respond to you
not the other way around
Dark Souls 3 on the other hand stays
true to those souls series routes you
play responsively and carefully so it's
not like blood-borne but it's not quite
as slow as previous souls games if that
makes sense
for example rolling was really fast we
were clad in really heavy plate and we
rolled around like it didn't matter it
was like the roll in blood-borne or the
fast roll of previous souls games to
counter this enemies also seemed to
attack a slightly faster hollows in
particular attack in frenzies and are
difficult to predict and all of the
knight characters we fought had shield
bash attacks that were intended to
punish super defensive players and I've
been playing blood-borne so much that I
just initially rolled around and didn't
use my shield but you get punished for
playing that way after a few hours of
play I was back to relying on my shield
again there was a medium shield that one
character had that was like the
drangleic shield from Dark Souls 2 in
that it blocked 100% physical damage and
the parry shield blocked
60% physical damage so it sounds like
the Perry shield is especially for pro
players to be honest since you're
missing out on all those power stance
attacks and I got to tell you it feels
good to be playing a Souls game again
instead of blood-borne
you're creeping around these levels and
you're constantly keeping your shield up
because there are a ton of ambush
moments in this demo enemies jumped at
you from behind barrels they played dead
then crept up behind you and they're
also coming at you over railings if you
don't have your shield up at all times
you're gonna get hit and getting hit
matters in this game it's not like
blood-borne where you can replenish your
health by hitting them back it's not
like Dark Souls 2 where there are life
gems s just works like it did in Dark
Souls 1 and that makes me so happy my
biggest problem with Dark Souls 2 was
actually life gems I hated how you could
buy ninety nine and keep your health
topped up constantly there was never
that threat of oh [ __ ] I just ran out of
Estus and now I have to find the bonfire
as soon as possible you know in Dark
Souls 3
Kailas Lee getting hit means that you
have to top yourself up with Estes and
it means that things get really exciting
when you have no Estes left and you have
a bunch of souls you don't want to lose
but you just want to push a little bit
further to find that bonfire I miss that
feeling so much and I sincerely hope
they don't bring back life gems and I
don't think they will when you chug your
Estes it's like Dark Souls 1 as well the
heal from the Estes is incredibly quick
just like you see here on the screen it
activates quickly and the health
replenishes instantly what's different
is what happens after the health
replenishes your character stands idle
for a good half a second after the chug
during which you can't move and you're
quite susceptible to damage I've slowed
it down on screen to show you what it
was like so
it's interesting because while you have
estes it's easy to stay alive but you
had better make sure you chug your estes
in a good spot because if you don't an
enemy will be easily able to hit you
after you chug your estes and punish you
it's like Dark Souls 1 in so many ways
let's go down the list we've talked
about parries we've talked about estes
let's talk about backstabs they're like
Dark Souls 1 as well
and I know that might make a lot of you
groan as soon as you position yourself
behind an enemy you can tap our one to
lock them into a backstab animation the
bad news is a lot of the enemies I faced
were able to be taken down with back
steps the good news is the window for
backstab seems to be slightly smaller
and enemies are much much better at
avoiding back stamps than they were in
Dark Souls 1 if you backstab fish a
hollow it's easy
there are hollow they have clumsy
movements and it's easy to take one out
with a backstab but if you attempt to
backstab and Knight you'll have a much
harder time they're trained to avoid it
they try to face you at all times and
they even have specific moves intended
to catch backstab fissures the shielded
Knights would often swing their shield
back over their shoulder to hit you and
had a bunch of shield bash attacks to
keep you away that said all it took was
a well-timed role or strafe through an
enemy combo to catch them in a backstab
so it's my impression that for a
one-on-one fight on average you'll
perform at least one backstab because
they're quite common and easy for a good
player to pull off one thing I'm glad is
back from Dark Souls 2 is directional
rolling while you're locked on and you
really do have to aim a lot of your
dodge as well because I noticed that
enemies seem to have a smarter AI in the
way that they surround you I would run
past a mob of enemies and when they
caught up with me they wouldn't just
attack they would huddle around me and
catch me in a corner to stop me running
away oh and another cool thing that
they've added is charge our two attacks
similar to blood-borne holding down our
two allows you to charge an attack for a
few seconds longer which adds damage and
stagger to your attack when you finally
do let it go
unlike in blood-borne there's no visual
or audio cue to the charging attack but
they're definitely there and it's
definitely powerful but in Dark Souls 3
there aren't as many move set options as
there were in blood-borne for example in
blood-borne you had running Artoo's
backstep attacks were different but in
Dark Souls 3 it's more like previous
souls games the only things that I
noticed that were different was that
you're running artoo is now a jump
animation and I also noticed that you
could do a running l1 attack when you
two-handed the Scimitar x' now let's
move on to story and how it was
presented so throughout the world there
were a few law notes that you could
activate these were called appetizers
appetizers are the words in memory of a
person who has died and they appeared on
a number of tombstones throughout the
level when you found one it gave you the
option to offer flame and this didn't
seem to take anything from your
inventory but once you did it you could
read the epitaphs I'm going to read you
the three that I found the first one was
grave of a nameless retainer raised his
sword for the Lord of cinder the second
one was this exile was chased from his
homeland and haunted by a black son and
the third one was died in solitude may
his soul find its way back to the frigid
valley the third one was incredibly
tough to get to it was the most hidden
thing in the whole demo actually he had
to find a hidden key and then you had to
find the door it unlocked and then you
had to defeat the most difficult thing
in the whole demo no joke this thing
wasn't even a boss but it should have
been this is him here this ice Knight
was so tough he attacked you
relentlessly and the fight challenged
every ability you had as a player you
had to manage your stamina you had to
roll through attacks when you were low
on stamina you had to choose the perfect
moment to heal and on top of all that
this guy induced to status effect that
no one has seen before it was called
frostbite and maybe people have seen it
before it was very similar to bleed so
if you stood too close to the night your
frostbite meter would build up and if he
hits you it would build up as well it
took about three or four hits for your
meter to reach full or perhaps about
five or six seconds standing right next
to him and when the meter did reach full
you were frostbitten which is kind of
like how bleed worked in Dark Souls 2
you now have a meter that goes down and
while it's going down your stamina
Bailey regenerates at all it regenerates
slowly as if you were holding your
shield up if you got frostbitten it
pretty much meant instant death in this
fight because
this enemy was totally relentless he
also took about 20 scimitar hits to kill
and it was really fun it took me about 3
or 4 tries to kill him which is what I
categorized as fun anyway I kind of made
that sound like a boss fight but it
wasn't it was just an enemy the boss
fight was actually way easier she was
called the dancer of the frigid wastes
and you see her in the trailer the most
difficult part about this fight was
anticipating attacks because she had
this really flowing move set that was
pretty hard to dodge I got her on my
second try no problems at all maybe
she'll be harder in the final game but
that's the thing we'll have to wait and
see before we can judge any difficulty
because so much is subject to change
from a demo and there's probably a lot
of other little things I could talk
about but I'm pretty sure this is most
of the important stuff if I haven't
mentioned it in this video it's probably
because it wasn't very interesting or
different from previous games for
example there were throwing knives
divine blessings fire bombs charcoal
pine resin and green blossoms in the
demo there were torches - except these
torches never run out
similar to blood-borne the enemies in
the demo were hollows hollow with shield
hollow with crossbow hollow with knives
ninja hollows a taller hollow with an
axe a taller hollow with a sword and
there were also demon dogs like in
blood-borne then there were hollows that
turned into writhing black masses there
was a fat Knight that used a OE magic
which was a little different and then
there were hollows with lanterns that
swung it around and aggro'd all the
passive hollows around her
in terms of nights there were nights
with long swords and a shield and there
was a knight with a spear and a great
shield and there was also the ice Knight
I mentioned before and a dragon that
breathed fire over the pathway you
needed to cross which is a Miyazaki
favorite so a very standard first dark
salt level but in true from software
fashion
there's no b-roll for me to currently
share so make sure you're subscribed so
I can show you some more gameplay as
soon as it surfaces and also make sure
you check out the channels of other
Souls uploaders who got their hands on
the game as far as I know Keith Peterson
dreaded code Lobos jr. Tara mantis
sunlight blade oroboro the ninja and by
an easy have all played this game so
I'll update the description with any
content from those guys I'm sure they
got some info that I missed and I'd
really appreciate it if you guys checked
out their channels and supported their
content as well but other than that
thank you for watching this video and
I'll talk to you again sir the way